um
agenda will deal with
recovery projects code of 19 that will
be coming up on the
public exclusive junior 19.3 welcome mr
chief executive
um
so the first we come to is reports 8.1
so that's on the
waku katahi low cost
risk program
thank you very much um so my fifth
report is on the low cost low risk
program funding which has been being
endorsed
by the work of cartagena for their needs
three years they're 20 21 to 24 in our
tp period
so this report is advising council that
um
bid to wakakoti of 13.2 million dollars
has not been involved in full
um 6.2 million dollars worth of projects
have been endorsed leaving us to short
fall of six point six three six months
that's amazing
um counts per share of that funding has
been allowed
for
how best to
deliver our critical works program and
to potentially look at balancing their
shortfall
what we're suggesting at this point is
that we proceed with some projects
and continue to advocate to what the
creative put additional funding on some
of these projects
we also have
a top up to 50
um
endorsement
where we have an ability to select one
or two small projects to progress
and the two that i have suggested is the
children
due to
the desire for a marine learning to
improve their cycling into a hearing
and also the townsend road culvert
extension project
um in the recommendations
i have a recommended council
in which they can
proceed with funding of the shortfall
and our minor safety area
the area is one where we do
a number of higher value projects that
are relatively low cost
and the funding short form there will be
425 000
i also recommended
that we progress with the design only
stage of
um
projects including burnside twists right
intersection
lots of controls upcoming
our walking and cycling program
in his valley and ireland i hope
intersection
the other reason for this
is that there may well be funding become
available over the next three years and
we have an opportunity to position
ourselves
to be able to take that funding off
quickly if it does become available
[Applause]
i think that that's probably the main
points from the report
i can't even take any third questions as
people have it
council thanks joey
um thank you joanne um just a question
for you you mentioned the tongues
anymore at coleman as you'd like to put
that
further out um
do you not find that that's um it's
quite a risk with a large amount of
traffic that goes down there it's very
very narrow and
wouldn't that shouldn't have been a high
priority do you think yes so sorry
rather than pushing it out what i'm
saying is that we should do that piece
of work wasn't the top up
that uh walker kotaki
is available
because i do agree it's an important one
for us to
progress
so when you say top up for monkey
is that out
6.7 or 7 million
of project money that was there which
there's only what five or six million
designers
open our endorsed program
yeah
was just
it was just under six million dollars
for
specific projects which had been
improved and then was around about 960
which could be used on other projects
um
with things with
the approval
and that allowed council some discretion
to
progress projects which are of a
particular or higher importance to a
council which is why the chillahi
footpath and
the townsend road culver extension are
the two that i'm suggesting to cancel
they give serious consideration
so we will we will attract the subsidy
if we put them in the program so that's
container
that's contained that's contained in b
is that what the
indicates the additional budget of 445
650 is there to do those projects so
that's for the minor safety
it's included
i was a little confused about that so
yep now that's a very good point it's
actually not clear in the
recommendations so potentially what we
could do is add an additional
recommendation which either approved or
what
unless there's further suggestions for
alternate projects to be progressed
if a councillor was minded not to move b
for instance
because
you want to put that extra money in
there but then
defeat the program that you're talking
about
so my recommendation would be that you
do progress would be and the reason for
that is the minor safety program
includes
all of our small
interventions including our school
safety program things like pedestrian
refuges outside schools
low
cost innovations around safety
as they occur in a program that gets
improved
through community boards and united yeah
okay
so
so the total budget that we
had in the minor it was around the low
cost budget was
i think 16 16 money was the zachary
and we got
seven about seven months
and we got we had 6.6
shortfall approved 6.6
but of that shortfall of 6.6
council has already allowed the share at
49 percent
so it's the waka kotahi tokyo percentage
as i mentioned there potentially will be
opportunities over the next three years
to apply for more funding
um and certainly that's where we would
like to position ourselves to be able to
get the best outcome of the council
okay so i'll come to other questions but
we need to think of some wording in
there around into a heavy for what path
and townsend broken culture is that
correct yes
if council was blinded too we could add
additional recommendation at the end
which either provided support or
not for one of those two projects
continuing from the top
my apologies
should have been incredible
so there's two heavy footpaths townsend
road caliber
so
what were the supports to a hearing
footpath and townsend marriage covert
being include
being included
in the watch program
this reminds me what we could say
is council supports
the uh procrastinating discussions with
kotahi on progressing to a hilly
footpath and townsend road extension
projects
subject to their approval
okay so we there could be a potential
eye if we're minded too okay
good question sir kirsten i mean
[Applause]
just um at d and e
we've got funding of the oxidizer and
charles upon drive rounded out at the
progressive design stage and here we've
got the classic road john's road
intersection safety improvements not
included
will there be more chance of serious
diesel injury on some of these rural
intersections with faster speeds than
there is on a residential
area which is only at 50 kilometer
and why has that priority been given to
a low-risk environment rather than a
risk environment
i wouldn't say oxford charles
is a low-risk environment it's a busy
road and that
we still currently have i guess vehicles
coming in from the town
into the area at a reasonable speed we
are obviously looking at reducing speed
through that area
we have got the active warning signs and
the net posts get strong so that has to
help with the
avenue event
um it's not saying we won't ever
progress with this i think it's more
just noting that it's one that we could
potentially push outside the three years
and then apply again through the nltp
more funding in the next three year
period
just
something through to that
wouldn't what's the time frame for
getting around about at the level
throughout john's uh oxford road corner
which would then progressively slow
traffic then to reduce that traffic
going forward i'm just wondering are we
putting our eggs in the right basket
yeah
yeah and that's a really good question
um i don't think the timing right in
front of me but it is within the ltp and
from memory it was about
five to six years out so
um lehman's john's
um part of the consultation was that
we've just been looking at with speed
limits and we'll be coming to the
community boards and council with over
the next month
is do we actually look at how we push
those speed limits out
so bringing that feedback is part of the
consultation back to council
okay
further questions counselors church
is the counselor stuart going to
navigate something or is that in a
second
just helps me
lost your name don't lost me
excuse me
why are we
having to reconsider this is there some
criteria that would
and
area running particularly
was one that was going to be pretty
highly contented
this in ltp and i think there's been a
number of reasons impacting that
including covert
and income
from history and kind of helped downtown
the road to zero
category and also
things like pt infrastructure
and rather than focusing on some of
these other areas of problems so i think
it's very much a
reflection
[Music]
any first questions
different parts of eroding rather than
some of these
bits and pieces
i think it just reflects
potentially
some challenges something with funding
around common
but also
a change in focus um things like the
road to zero area through the gps is in
the area that they want
government to want to and
i guess concentrate
so the second question on this
um is
uh funding the um
then transport um sheriff
that sets the president for that and are
they likely to look at the next funding
rounds and think why their career
council are going to fund it themselves
that we don't need to is there any
potential of that thought going into
their process
i don't think they're particularly
looking at one council or another or
what they want or won't fund
i think this is more driven in a
national level in terms of where
government wants to see
uh transport investment
to achieve the objectives of the gp's
[Applause]
not all got fifty percent that's quite
unknown
i know uh sal and my friends were
sitting in a very similar situation
so i don't i think as a region
um
my understanding is that the family
looks around this sort of level
i'm not aware of people
fully funded in their life
um
you talk about
not enough funding because the cows are
getting off the road you talked about a
change to what they're doing
so
why would we put any future programs in
there hoping we would get funding
these challenges that you've just
mentioned to us
and what you are not going away so why
would we even consider
putting these in here and not going with
a
totally different secret program next
year because
the indication if i read you right then
you've just given me that there isn't
any funding and because of the
situations you just said there won't be
so why would we
do that
[Applause]
i'm not
sure
i guess the question but
we
when we put our program forward we try
and i just pitch our projects
in terms of
um trying to take the box which is
and
put the information in that we have for
those projects forward to kotapi as part
of that but
there's always an opportunity for us to
i just do more work and try and make
sure we're pushing that correctly and at
the right level
but the reality is there will always be
some projects that have a higher
priority and it may not be that we are
providing
um
i guess enough
emissions reduction as an example or
enough enough mind shift to be able to
attract each other that's
decides to put forward all of these
projects
um
in the future
or whether it's just whether we're just
going to work there's some real
complications in this that i see and
particularly around the questions that
council williams has just asked
um
does it just put in front of us today
without a workshop
and i'm just i'm a bit
i'm a bit confused about behind like
watching fun i can i can see the
questions that are coming from more
links on this and i similarly have some
similar
concerns so perhaps it might be joey is
there anything if we were to progress
this by workshop and find a slime is
there anything
preventing that that would be putting
this at risk in the interim
so the one i just think that i
um
with our minor improvements programme
for this financial year my safety
program and the reason for that being we
already have an approved program
which has been agreed with uni and that
has
i guess some important projects that we
were
progressing and they increased things
like the
pedestrian facilities outside tomato
school
so trying to produce those low cost
improvements perhaps we just haven't
paused for a moment and maybe yourself
the chief executive and i can just have
a wee
conference um and uh we just have a
brief agenda and we'll just discuss a
way forward that would be right members
say back in about five or ten minutes
[Applause]
uh
it was still going when i
um
oh
is
um
foreign
much easier to hear talking not very
fast
thank you
oh
christianity
[Music]
is
she
um
[Music]
is
um
[Music]
he is okay
on the floor
is
just
she's
he's
okay
um
and we've determined that uh
through the conversation hopefully
you're in agreement with this 8.1 and
8.2 will lay on the table
uh we will have a workshop
um
during november and we can shoot you
along with the view that the reports
will come to the same time
you're moving procedurally that we do
say
second
um next is um
productive budget uh carriers i
understand kelly and kelly are coming to
jira
gracie
there's
all right so thank you
so first of all apologies from jared who
was due to present this report so this
relates to our current financial year
2021-22 capital works program
uh so
it's a report that we do not like
bringing to council as it does signal
that we have a number of projects um in
three waters and also solid waste that
must be delivered
in the 21-22 financial year
so those projects are estimated under
recommendation b
um
these are the projects that will
definitely be carryovers so let's see
ashley street
pipe upgrades and drainage project
school roads drainage upgrades
and that relates to also to the box
stream improvement works also in
woodland and a wastewater project being
our septage facility
so we have we no longer have any
dedicated internal resources to work on
these projects
there's also a range of projects under
recommendation c
that will be
progressed this financial year but at
risk of
not being completed it will
will likely be carryovers so that is
um southpaw
ponzi access best works for pub station
modifications
cones road drain upgrade
and there are some solid waste projects
being the south resource recovery park
disposal upgrade liner improvement works
in the oxford transfer station football
alterations
and you'll note in
itunes 4.1 of the report on page 63 that
there are a number of projects that we
have packaged up and put out to a
consultant externally
so that is the design of the york street
drainage
diversion and then some
msqa which is the construction
monitoring for three projects bringing
the
central regular stage five that's the
one coming up to king street past the
school and towards dudley park
wooden road rising maine
and looks according to green street
stormwater upgrade project
there are also a number of projects that
are listed in
4.2 that
we are still intending to deliver but
they are dependent on
us being successful with recruitment
that we have underway at the moment
the final thing just to note is that as
part of our annual plan commentaries we
will be
uh covering up the impact implications
of this in terms of our
2223 capital works program to make sure
that we're in a position to deliver next
year's capital works program
thank you have to take any questions
okay
okay questions
counseling yeah the wastewater secrets
soldier that was meant to be a
money-making scheme for the council as
well
is that
which would cover the cost and
i understand it was sort of a reasonable
um
amount of money the council would
actually make on it but it wasn't going
to be a cost cost for the council
uh it is correct so
um
there has been a lot of work put into
that and it does pay for itself it's got
about a seven year
return on investment for that acceptance
disposal facility
uh
where we hope to get to this financial
year is purchasing the unit
and getting it into the country it has
quite a long lead time in about 26 weeks
so half a year
but we will not complete the civil works
this financial year and have it
operational so that is a project that um
we will make some progress on in terms
of purchasing the unit but it won't be
completed
so what is
um yeah so we've
been having a look at other setups
around the country our preferred
device that we are looking at purchasing
there is no other similar
installation in new zealand so we are
just going through our due diligence to
make sure that the device that we're
committed to is the best solution
any further questions
you've got a recommendation
signed by council brian we wish to speak
um
just to say that it is the support and i
suppose in some respects that we do have
to carry over some projects but i
understand i suspect there is a
resourcing issue
and um that's something beyond our
control so
on aware staff are probably under
pressure to deliver
hopefully as much as they can so i think
we
need to support this
council
any further speakers
i've got the recommendation although mr
thank you
[Applause]
uh now come to 8.4
representation review of arrangements
governance manager
sometimes
i will save the report as read however
there was a couple of minor
administration changes to the
recommendations
uh recommendation a the
report number actually changes to
2.1022170978
and recommendation
h
i would like to
um
retain
one two and three of h and then make a
new i
which comprises of
what was section four
which
resolves that the membership of the
green euro actually community board
comprised of late elected members being
six members from the
regular subdivision and two members of
the
ashley subdivision
along with four members of the council
representing the ashley razier ashley
award and appointed to the community
board for reasons of fair representation
across the regular ashley ward
and that therefore tinies up that
recommendation
in line with recommendation b because
this is the only change that we are
proposing for the representation review
the number of board members the wrangler
actually would remain the same but we
moved from
three to two members for the ashy
subdivision
and
we increase from five to six in the
rangiora urban subdivision so we
actually are just required to spell out
a little bit clearer
on why there is a change there as
opposed to retaining what we've
currently had
so sarah just to go at it again in the
recommendation
you're changing the words in
uh 0.5 is that correct
results that the membership of the
regular ashley community board and risk
that remains the same
for reasons of fair representation
across the regular ashley
you got that adrian no sorry
i hope you got it written down sir
yes
is this
this is recommendation i no that's fine
[Music]
well we don't know we need to be clear
on what we're voting on now though so h
is there because in our recommendations
i'm going to give it lost
on page 69.
[Music]
so one two and three of that section
remain unchanged
so it is
and it just adds the words at the end
of their representation across the
regular action so that's the only change
is that
everyone's clear on that yeah
therefore we're spelling out the reasons
for our change
and that is the only proposed change
to the current representation
arrangements based on all the feedback
that we have
received and working through the process
okay thank you any questions sorry if
you have anything else you wish
um no after today we will place an
advertisement in the local paper and the
priests
advising of today's decision
that will be out for a month for appeal
and any appeals then go to the local
government commission
should there be
the local government commission or hear
those and make a determination
probably in march
[Applause]
any questions
we've got the recommendation
i'm happy to move seven seconds a second
so
just
moving just look i think sarah
probably a really good process on this
it's clear that past
work has actually contributed well
there's been a lot of work that's got
have gone on the past
to make sure that our representations
were
have us well placed and in the end this
came down to the regulation community
board simply around the population
uh the year ultimately with the change
it was conversation of members of the
war there was a board representative as
part of the
working parties so i think we have
and we've been out for the public and
so we've we've got a fair few back
um from that and as you say this down
by approving this today follows the
process of its own
with your
rights
period of time so
um i just commend you and
you know and other staff and also the
working party for their role in shaping
that's where we've opted
because change is always quite difficult
i'm glad that we've managed to remain
the parameters that we've seen in the
previous round however i do want to just
put a word of caution we can see that
our district is becoming more urban
but we are still a period of district we
have a very very large rural area so
it's going to become increasingly
important and that those members and our
community boards are very aware of the
rural sections of their walls and we're
seeing this with larger voices being
heard from the towns
it
and that is
is that they they remember that
some of our district doesn't actually
have sewer water rubbish and facilities
outside the
thanks sarah
um
um we're advised like that simon can't
be here
so
[Applause]
thank you um thank you
so we've got
there's no startups
this report but is there any major
items members have otherwise we can lay
it on the table if we need to until next
meeting but it seemed really
straightforward to me
is that
you have the rest of reading there
[Applause]
um yes thank you mr media it's pretty
self-explanatory
and uh almost just for procedural the
permission for the um
the deed to be um it was given by
council and approved by um
the
exercise
see i'm offering it thank you very much
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say i
can't hear that carry i'm sorry about
the feedback on the microphones but
we're just bearing in the intramurals a
new system
coming in the not the distant future
which hopefully will resolve the
feedback issues we've received
okay um come to item nine there's no
items referred
i think the key point is that there
haven't been any
notifiable incidences
should be reported on this
obviously they're not being reported um
are they going to be and i'll go protect
you to the ones the big cyclone truck
had next and the other
the week um i'll hit lean post for the
truck what have you and
are we going to get contractors
reports
we are working on a system to bring
those two so in the future that's the
attention
okay um you have questions we've got a
recommendation you prepared to move
second advice
i hope
um any discussion
all that's important to say
is there anything you wish to
say
okay
if you're the speakers i've got that all
those in fact please say aye
contrary to carriage
there's no correspondence
item 14 is
vermeer's diary
um something
moved by council records and seeking the
vote
okay
always perfectly say
portfolio updates that just remind
members it's um three minutes up to
three minutes
ceo's gonna stop watch the issues at the
start for me
just to say on the other ewe
relationships
with the
workshop this past meeting
we presented on
our council's view on the three waters
subject and
we had a range of questions from
our representatives but it's pretty much
the main
items that were raised there
so i'm going to take any questions as
there are
greater christ future partnership um
just um
we talked around the uh we had a
workshop out at lincoln which uh all
members were invited along to which was
walking around
effectively the start of the spatial
planning work which is really important
and
we started to see some draft of some
maps
indicating where growth could go we've
started a very interesting conversation
um going forward around
the appropriateness or otherwise of
where development should go we of course
are ambitious for our district and
there'll be an opportunity for you guys
to feed into that as we
continue this work over the next 12
months
the greater irish 2050 work which is
talking about our ambitions for the next
30 years
is
getting to a point of conclusion so this
is finalizing that document at the
moment and
the last meeting of the partnership was
the agreement on the
over growth partnership which critically
uh bring in two cabinet ministers to our
process
uh ministers marketing which will be an
interesting conversation on our majors
and
the minister of housing
one thing that's happened in the last
month of course is that
some announcements would be on the um
urban growth um
eps national policy statement on
movement growth so as you know we've got
a workshop on it next week to talk about
the implications
any questions
as i mentioned earlier this morning
pc7
will be considered by an extraordinary
meeting weekend on november the 17th and
but the agenda which contains the
the plan change will be publicly
available on the november league
i mean this has as you we all know real
significance for the farming and
environment in
korea
and i'm disappointed personally that
this council did not seem fit
to make a submission on
natural wetlands and the
definition and provisions
to mfv which is part of the
clarification of the mps freshwood from
last year
submitted
i thought we didn't there didn't seem to
be an appetite from staff to
respond to it
i thought in the very least we could
have supported each and submission and
or
targets but certainly
leaving a gap it doesn't sit well with
me at all because it is of huge
significance
to protecting the wetlands we have here
um
i did want to um
there is quite a and i mentioned it this
morning
under the cwms which is
really
nothing but a
paper document
in the sense that there is real
frustration
within the zone committee about what is
their role
project
in the taranaki and also
earmarked potentially
20 grand or so towards the spark
northbrook
track and corridor
that has been developed up and
internally there is some support
i would like to
also show you this which it was this is
the ashley river
um projects from ecan which appeared on
his own
table as they do just drop it down
yesterday
and to great consternation from the zone
committee they had never seen it before
no public involvement there is also the
rangiora reach master plan that is as a
result of the
vegetation clearance that could cause a
lot of
this is how it's been presented and the
committee the committee did
voice its concern that this was the
first time they'd seen anything like
this got projects on they go no nothing
about
um and
really questioned what an earth
engine was doing and dropping stuff like
that
and i would
endorse
concerns
you're three and a half minutes i'll
just i'll just wrap it up yeah
as you know
the in the recent flood there was
fifteen hundred cubics at kines road and
we were in
liverpool tease the stop being system
in 2003 it was recommended um to move to
a design network of 3000 q necks with
600 millimeters free board nothing has
happened
and ecan at the meeting acknowledged
that at 1500 units there was real danger
in fact we evacuated at that level
um if if the stock meets at the moment
designed for 2 400 qmex if it had got
anywhere near that they would have burst
it would have been in ring europe
ecan is now undertaking a review
of what is the level of risk that the
community is willing to
to
work with
it would have been carnage to quote he
can had there been a two thousand two
and a half thousand cubic flood
through there um the stopbacks wouldn't
have held up
uh and the recommendation is that
going back to even 2009 that
um perhaps even four thousand four and a
half thousand so
we need to get involved in this as a
council because this is happening at 18
and we don't have any input into it at
this moment okay
thank you council stuart can i
understand the first point you raised
around the submission i'll ask the chief
executive to follow up what happened
there because i certainly wasn't aware
of any other member was but
um he says of course
well it should be we should be
submitting on things generally where it
should come to elected members for our
view so i don't know what's occurred
there so we'll follow the number the
other is his
chief executive and i have been
involved in some early conversations and
their agreed to here
um
around some of their work that he are
looking to do on the stock banks but
they've engaged a gentleman called
bezel chamberlain to come in and
undertake some of that work but there
will be there will be there will be need
to come here and have further
conversation and briefings with the
council because it's a serious issue
and um you can't have put a
the engineer that gave the talk was a
guy called matt sermon
who was doing the ashley scheme review
so i don't know how
relationships
next time
very patient when you're waiting
all right um regen um
thank you not a lot to report there's a
few things floating around in the wood
we've had four
applicants come to us to discuss
on the
lake bouncy castle project that is all
go the thing has arrived from china it's
it goes paris hamilton on its way south
um they're aiming to open on the 25th of
um this month
um
that is a deliberate ploy to get in a
week before prom will open their one
so they can ride on their publicity
and
resource consensus through from us and
from ecam so the project is all good
because it's been granted the licensure
occupiers filled with prices being
funded both concerns are through here
okay um questions of counter questions
uh
climate change and sustainability
council meetings
points on the annual report on the 2021
organizational sustainability plan
implementation will be coming to audit
and risk on the 16th of november so you
won't hear about that i'm not sure who's
going to be presenting it
but
um
and the regional climate change risk
assessment documents currently being
finalized and
as well as that
we are progressing some work to provide
a set of climate change scenarios for
our district
that as far as possible will reflect the
recently updated ipcc projections
and also they are um
establishing a district level emissions
profile
which shall be interesting to see how
that comes out
as you all are all aware as we speak cop
26 is going on in glasgow so we'll see
what comes out of that
um
i'll hold my breath
and
far as on a more local level if you look
out the window there there is a flamingo
e-scooter parking lot which is kind of
exciting i guess so we launched that
from um
yesterday
and
um
yeah that's pretty much about it for me
thanks nikki
thanks nikki any questions
uh council williams
did you get an yeah from james shore to
glasgow
i would have turned it down
yeah there was a thing called zoom
all right okay thanks nikki
um thanks to the working party by
council reckons and others that have
considered that better get it to where
it is today
okay uh 15.7 business promotion and town
centres council award
thank you i've got quite a lot to say
today
um just to find the promotions within
three minutes
um
it will be
don't stop me now don't start
promotions um i've been greatly affected
by the co-workers celebration that's
been cancelled in the euro the business
awards have been cancelled
um and but we're hoping to still have a
christmas parade in regular but
we'll have to see but on the town
centres
um sorry
okay
there we go
what was that sorry
there you go so thank you
e-scooters of course are now available
across the district for public to use
so
around
the six-month trial will run through
until the end of april
at which council will consider how
public east filter services might look
into the future staff will work with
flamingo over the course of the trial to
monitor use behaviour
as part of the trial council receive
ongoing data relating to how the
scooters are being used to the district
ev charging stations electric vehicle
charging status and they're up and
running in both vanguard and quietly
town centres
planning for the implementation of woody
and oxford charging stations level one
the change in location that oxford has
been successfully negotiated with
meridian energy after further feedback
from the oxford i hope aboard was
received the oxford charges now will be
located at the pearson park car park
rather than the town hall
new zealand motor caravan association
have now been granted resource consent
for their proposed motor caravan park at
the kaiapoi east
business regeneration area the final
lease agreement arrangements should also
be concluded over the next couple of
weeks
some delays to this project were
incurred as a result of ongoing covert
interruptions over the last year but the
ndmca are now in the process of
finalizing the site works arrangements
the current project plan has ended mca
contractors commencing work outside on
site
this side of christmas and being ready
to receive guests by the end of march
so
they will receive up to 150 caravans at
any one time
the coinboy southwest youth business
area
development proposal
staff have agreed and finalised finer
details with the momentum of
understanding with the preferred
proponent in both council and the
preferred proponent have begun
undertaking the further investigation
tasks related to this proposal this
includes an initial meeting with econ
engineers and regulatory staff and a
similar meeting with waimakariri
district council engineers in regulatory
staff your number of feasibility
viability and concentrability tasks will
be undertaken over the next six months
staff will update council as appropriate
with regards to the ongoing progress of
this project and the current shift or
we'll see the report coming back to
council august september 2022
with recommendations as to whether
council should proceed to the further
stage of a formal development agreement
an initial public communication about
this process is currently being
developed by the council's
communications team is likely to go up
next week beginning the 8th of november
um
rengara town central
[Music]
restrictions
um have been undertaken this review has
resulted in a number of small
recommended changes to parking
restrictions time in some areas so like
onto that bank of new zealand's site
simon h and roy will be providing a
quick briefing to council regarding the
site awaited the council's next briefing
next tuesday
freemasons have recently advised the
desire to consider an alternative option
to the one previously discussed
and so but this does not um
necessarily prevent the opportunity
of us wanting to enable access through
crystal street to council's public copa
and locally at last but not least local
economic development strategy staff will
be going by project brief and scope and
under taking
initial research for the upcoming local
economic development strategy review and
refresh 50 000 k
has been included in the current
financial year for this project
and staff see this strategy as being an
opportunity shape and guide council
enterprise for canterbury economic
development activities for the
foreseeable future staff will be
engaging with the buddhist and risk
committee over the coming months as
planning for this project continues
thank you jane
any questions
just like to say with that news around
the center parade or something that's
really sad
i suspect oxford will follow suit
because the president of oxford lions
called me the other day to find out what
was going on
so i'll pass that on to him but i know
our community will be really
disappointed that's certainly a
highlight for all of us
those of us that still believe about
christmas
um he loved the parades but i've
absolutely understand the position of
the promotions associations around
it's really sad because it's something
we all look forward to but the christmas
tree festival is going ahead don't know
that's what we've been doing well i've
got a text earlier i'm not sure about
that they are looking for some guidance
from us before
i really do
okay
um any questions
um
the information is by the leg
still happening or is that
likely to be called off as well it's a
christmas address it's a sentence that's
a separate of me i guess they'll have to
take care of it
that doesn't come hasn't come
okay
okay so um we have no question i have no
questions
um
no agent general business
we now move to uh measures to be
considered with the public excluded
there's a recommendation someone commit
to me
that